hey hey guys how's it going uh we were
sent a game called albino lullaby and i
think i'm gonna give it a try and check
it out my name is mary thanks for
joining me
and uh this is an indie game made by a
studio called ape law and it seems like
they're a little newer and
what's interesting is kind of headed by
justin papas who was the lead level
designer behind bioshock he also was a
level designer for chivalry
and tomb raider so it sounds pretty cool
um the image that i saw was terrifying
and i'm just kind of curious to check it
out so i'm just going to
jump right in in it and let's see see
what this is all about
in between
there are things known
there are things unknown
was a perception whoa
bubbles
remember
i remember an accident
72 i'm going the speed limit oh god
lullaby
okay
i
can see
a lot of white
i wonder if this is what it looks like
to albinos
super white
everything's
really white
okay
looks like i'm in a cage
welcome home child
thank you
bubbles
yeah
oh my god
i think my cage just fell
all right
got some moving ooh i can jump that's
great
let's try to jump on out
and
looks like i can sprint
well my cage is super dark
there we go that's where i was in this
cage
i fell out of
i'll go down this red
death alley
left shift to run thank you
do not press button
boop
oh whoa
this kind of has like
you guys remember that movie um
i think it's
13 ghosts it's got
like um a house or something and then
all the rooms shift and then monsters
come out of the different rooms
it's like glass or something it's really
creepy
um it kind of reminds me of
that what kind of room is this
whatever
all prisoners must be fully sedated
lift to surface
oh there's some funky tracks here
looks like
so many movie references that just
reminds me of casper
that part where they ride the um
this chair into
they're like getting shaved and stuff
getting ready
oh
family only all right
okay i'm not allowed in there i'm not
not family
bug
bugs bugs bugs these are all the same
photo
there's no reason for that
boop
oh okay
i'm already kind of getting
the same kind of vibe that i would get
from
kind of like feels like rapture in some
of these places the saturated colors
like the dark scheme
with highlights
matteo
no
stop using my secret washroom that's for
me
when i'm on shift you can use the
toilets upstairs if you have to go you
really make me uncomfortable
using my toilet you keep leaving your
stuff in there after your shift i know
you've been touching my special seat
stop it i hate you i'm going to bite you
i'll bite you
well
seems reasonable i don't like people
using
my seat either we all have a special
seat
boop
oh
it's pretty cool when the chairs do that
um
kind of helps
give weight to the fact that these rooms
are shifting dramatically
ah key
yoink
is that a urinal
i guess it's just a toilet
i suppose that makes more sense
dusky land
the old
dusky land to read while you're
going to the bathroom
everybody needs something they've chosen
dusky land
i don't think there's anything else i
can do in here
i mean already this game seems to me
like it's more atmospheric
than it would be
like
just blatant
jump scares like it doesn't
i could be wrong like somebody could pop
out and kill me at any moment but
to me this kind of feels like
oh there was a key in here maybe i can
get in now
um
huzzah
kind of feels like it's more of a
mental
scare which um
you know like the long scare which if
anything has more of a long longer
lasting impression than a simple jump
scare
anyone caught peeping at the ascension
from here will be gravely punished
reporting friends reaps greater reward
whatever snitches get stitches i'm not
doing that
everybody knows the golden rule
well there's another note
they all have a hole in the same spot
one has a hole like the same lower left
they're not taking care of their paper
someday one will wake up right in the
middle till then i'll watch everyone in
hope
middle of what
all right let's go this way
caution the bridge is passable
but blocked is chosen
oh i see a key
what does that say
head something key here
well there's i'm terrible at reading
backwards type
there's definitely
a key
so let's head towards
that direction and see if we can obtain
another key
i also kind of want to follow these
tracks
i'm a little curious about the tracks
oh my god
oh i hate chairs like that
not that i've ever been in one
um
it's just more like a
casual comment that nobody really likes
these chairs
it's kind of like a half
dentist chair half
creepo chair
are they just
i believe this is the sedation chair
that makes sense
i'm just curious
i like the way it moves you know like
it's so
cool looking when you
when you
change the rooms the mechanical movement
of everything looks
really nice
again it kind of gives me that bioshock
feel like that
homey feel but then there's like this
gross technological
side that to me looks
really creepy and makes you kind of hate
i don't know
gears and stuff like that just
feels uncomfortable
this is like an interesting texture
looks like unfinished but probably on
purpose
where am i
am i allowed to be in here
i have no idea where i am
all right whatever uh caution
okay it seems like a reasonable fear
the bridge is passable blocked
i don't
see
what i'm supposed to do i'm gonna jump
off this for a second go back up and see
if i can find some kind of
ah a button i love buttons
okay let's see
now it's
not possible
that's not passable
oh
no no no
i think i just
effed up
redo
i'm damn it
no
is it supposed to jump on there totally
well
i died
i burned death
well [__]
you try harder this time i'm doing my
darndest
i'll try this way maybe there's
well it doesn't look
any better
can i do anything in here
i don't see anything to touch
all right whatever
i will move on
and i will try the fire thing again
um
i have
good feelings about
this one let me
pick up the speed a little bit
oh my god it's so hard to see
oh god and i get stuck
there we go
oh no am i stuck
stuck
oh it doesn't want me doing that i don't
think
i can't
get
out
[__]
i think i'm stuck it won't let me move
i can go back and forth
but once i'm out i can't jump
i can't move i can't crouch
so i might have
well i might have busted it i might have
to go back
to an earlier save or something
that sucks
i don't want to resume
can i go to my last
i really don't want to start a new game
that sucks
i'm being told i have to start a
freaking new game cause i got stuck in
the window so great
here we go again can i skip this
well i guess you shouldn't go through
the window
i mean granted this is just a demo and i
know these guys are on kickstarter right
now so it seems like this is something
where they're probably
still getting
everything in order
it's also possible that
i couldn't move and somebody else could
have done it
um
but it's
damn it's definitely possible
to get through this i'm sure um
so we will just try it again sorry guys
let's do it one more time all right
i was hoping to like
have a save that sucks to do this all
over again
maybe i'll notice something different
this time
all right let's do it again
sprinting through this
looks like standard controls um shift to
run
e interacts um
control appears to be like some kind of
you know like standard crouch
pc
i'm gonna touch everything i did before
just so that
uh that doesn't like
glitch out the game in any way where
they're like you didn't do the same
things that you were supposed to do so
i'll do all the stuff but i'll just do
it really quickly
oh yeah read this
mess with this
all right go into here get key off
toilet
could be like a speed run
uh
use key in family room family fun time
read note about peepin
read note about
being in the middle
okay so this time
i'm gonna jump on that damn bridge
did i do it
it did it right
it's there
okay
so i know i moved this stuff i have to
go get it right so i go
i can't remember exactly where i'm
supposed to go i followed these tracks
this is what killed me okay
so
nice try
so i go in here
go down into the tunnel of death
here we go okay
okay
so
that comes up i believe
so when i push this button
when do i do it
suck it
fire
all right
sorry i went quiet for a little bit i
had to i had to concentrate
do not leave buffet unrefrigerated
hey my key
hang cage
that's what it said hang cage
sweet breads those are clearly pears
but
that's all right
jellied offal i don't know what that is
and meat stew that's meat stew i know it
means too it looks like tripe
again clearly a pear
giant pear
all right well
success
you know it's interesting
it's interesting like
how long it took me to do that the first
time but i do it again and honestly it
wasn't
it took like no time at all
so
that's
interesting
all right where am i
okay
some creepy room with a elevator
oh a note to recite in unison as the
cage ascends aramis
equando
secret to
i don't speak spanish
we were once as is you now are above in
the deep below our numbers are many our
family is strong we are no longer you
but not yet us have you become oh that
means rise to our love brother and see
without eyes wrapped in the warm
wet embrace of our grandest elder mother
you will know of our vibrance and gnaw
at its liver welcome welcome our fluid
is your fluid we love you child remain
silent
until the cage is no longer in sight
now please enjoy the fine buffet
do not leave the flyer behind
somebody left the flyer behind
all right i want to go there that's
where i want to be
uh
to recite nina said two people left the
flyer behind
two people
did not read the rules any secrets
okay
you people are bad
luck
oh piece of paper
look at that
ooh piece of paper oh piece of paper
up again another person left their flyer
you guys are bad nobody's listening to
the rules
well that's not foreboding
it's so
saturated this is such a
lock
yeah
such a creepy
i was there there was another kind of
creepy game that used elevators to like
descend and it was just terrifying
because it's like
there's just something about an elevator
that makes you feel like
well i'm going
up so that's not as scary there's
something about like going down an
elevator it's like
this is creepy
the basement of anything
invokes like gross
creepy memories hey it's the poop book
dusky land and
some matches
wouldn't let me pick them up
you hear that
terrible pianos again
like reminds me of an eerie
uh rapture type thing
we'll be sending one up to you shortly
picked up from an auto accident hey
that's me
wash up and get your mask prepped to
lock the door so your brothers leave you
alone this time you earned this
so this is the guy that
comes and and sees me
can i pick that up
no
can't have that note
looks like a note to me
i'm a beeping tom
i'm peeping
they know the rules about peeping
is that my
that's my crouch
it doesn't crouch
does he have a mustache
creepy
let's take this key
should i open up this door
oh my god i thought that was that guy
coming to kill me
p.s i didn't mention this before but
what the hell is that
pretty dark can he
feel like this is when it starts getting
real
all the other times it was not real
dinner dinner
is that on
that's not safe
is that the beef stew
do you guys hear something
i'm starting to get freaked out
you know what's freaky about wide spaces
is sometimes
they're worse than
tight areas because i just like i'm
worried that like
there's a lot of space in here for [__]
to go wrong
buck is
is
contained
green so it sounds like buck is
contained which is great
and the way i would prefer it
sure
i don't give a [__]
this appears to be
the dining room
mary was killed in the dining room
with the buck
get booked
what does that
say see all this cool stuff
and i'm just like
fearlessly going to find it without any
like worries that something will kill me
water emulsion therapy is beneficial to
your health kind of looks like a
waterboarding chamber to me
but i don't really
get therapy
can i go in there
i'll click on this creepy button first
and then i'm back in the dining room
okay so this looks like
so i'm in the same dining room
there's dos kitchen so i turned on this
one and i turned on
one in there
where else haven't i been
it seems like a place you could easily
get
lost
in oh god what's that
stairs
more of the bug
be sure buck is contained if these three
lights are green so i'm looking for a
third lights
i mean they know that's scary why would
they put it up
why
i'm in the toilet chamber oh god it's
the third one
i don't understand are those just a
bunch of toilets in a circle like that
sounds awful
all right i'm gonna click this and then
run up there for safety
did anything bad happen
doesn't seem like anything bad happened
buck wasn't released
okay
no book
i want to open that but i
don't have the key so
i have a feeling i'm supposed to be
finding a key pretty soon
it's interesting the way they did these
levels um
you know like in some cases when i found
that key i saw this chamber through the
window and i knew that's where it wanted
me to go but this time
i've seen the chamber first well the
elevator i suppose and i know that i
need a key
so they're doing it
in a few different ways
i'm gonna
i wanted to jump on that person's bed
but they got too much [__] on it
oh look tripe also known as pears
this person just
has that by their bed
it's weird
it's pretty dark i hope i didn't miss
anything in there
if you guys saw something like a piece
of paper scream at me in the chat if not
i'm going to continue through this
pee room
there is nothing
i see you
bm log is that bowel movement log
who's sitting the best and longest pogo
15 minutes bren's
four hours i was very well behaved today
joe 27 hours nero
well somebody didn't go
bren 12 hours i slept here good lord
grosh and ben ben apple seeds i don't
know what that means
that's gross
we were so different when we were
children how have we augmented so
grandmother would say we lost the path
this painting reminds me of too much
what we used to be i
must have it removed that's what you
used to be
a rabbit
suit
ghost
it's getting creepy
be sure buck is contained
oh
lord
that would have squished me
i bet you that might be something that
happens later is that like if you're not
ooh loading i've progressed
um if you're not like paying attention
you can get like super squished
ah fire
i'm going to warm
my butt
i'm crouching
but
warming
electricity
that makes sense
gotta have electricity before the button
yay
oh it doesn't it's not as impacty as i'd
like
i just want to like jump in
sploosh it does make sploosh noises
though there's that ooh paper
bill searched and searched but he found
nothing surely there's
more to this rat maze something to touch
something to eat he thought but merely
stared into the void
and the void did not stare back well
it's a void it can't stand back still
sightless it beckons
in many ways i'm still like incredibly
lost as to the story of this game
this like
the pieces of the puzzle i know are so
few like i was in a
is there somewhere to go i'm missing
you know like
oh there's a thingy up there i want to
go up there probably
you know that like i
i was in a car wreck and i
ended up here in this cage and
there's buck
oh it sounds like they're like trying to
control me maybe like i'm one of the
people that are
that they're controlling
i don't know how do i get up there
is that a door
it's got green light under it
looks like
something i'm supposed to
no
all right whatever
try this one
like it looks like they want me to go
that way
and then what's up with this
just like caged in here
should i just
push it again
oh this isn't where i was before
this is a new place
paper
oh
so
getting creepier as it goes
i cannot read you there we go jim please
come out it's been five years your
brothers miss you the longer
you're in there jim
it's not the right you're
the worse your punishment
will
b are the texts is the text off that
paper
i think it is it's hard to tell
what exactly are you doing in there
no
i'm all out in there
it
really motivated me to make me feel like
i was supposed to go in there i really
wanted to go
all right again i'm stuck
what's that
is it always there
starting to set and guess everything i
do
i guess i'll just push the button again
no big deal
oh my freaking god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god fix it fix it fix it fix it
fix it fix it fix it fix it fix it fix
it fix it fix it fix it fix it
god
oh my god
oh they're pissed
oh my god where am i going where am i
going where am i going where am i going
shut up
i'm losing it
i'll push this
take me somewhere
oh my god
like again like they don't need jump
scares or anything like i'm freaking out
where are they
i could hear them they were so pissed at
me
what am i doing
should i push the button again
i don't think i can do anything in here
what's happening
they're rotating the floor around me
all right
boop
i bet you want me going there don't you
don't you
okay
oh god am i like i'm in a sideways room
i'm so confused
that's a door
[__]
i didn't mean to fall
i feel like
if i
oh my god
are these
i'm gonna
i'm gonna touch it
i think they're dead
where am i
like where did i pop out of
i'm telling you it's like that movie
where the rooms
rotate oh where the [__] am i
all right i'm running
what oh i think i'm doing
he's gonna take my eyes
have you earned your visit
really like
what's that noise
i don't know what to do i don't want to
should i try to kill it
i don't have any
arms
uh
okay
it's kind of like spiders maybe they're
more scared of me
than i am of them
but they're they can kill me
are they looking for me
looks like they wanna
so i
can't
fell into those dead ones
there's a bunch of live ones over there
what's that
can i get there
am i allowed to be oh my god
what the frick to do
oh my
all right
running
i can't see
for [__] oh my god where am i going
oh what's that
i can't see i can't see
am i going this way
am i going the right way
i could be going wrong i go backwards
for elena
is this right
okay
this seems fair
going in
can i close this behind me
i mean they're doing a really good job
at like naturally scaring me i don't
feel like
oh god those totems are so creepy
clothes
oh
those guys were dead when i got there
what's up with grandma
i wanna meet that grandma
i don't know what i just did
do i not want that
i'm super confused
did i f it up
i might have left it up
i really don't want to start again
because maybe this is what they wanted
me to do
like i can't go back down right this is
that's not right
am i
i feel like that'll kill me
and i don't like jumping through windows
anymore after the last window incident
all right let's go back down
oh
right
so i think i tripped the
wire that makes him say that speech
i don't know what to do
won't
i feel like i was supposed to go in that
damn door but what was the button for
then
like i could have just gone in here but
i pushed the button first
now i don't know
where to go
because that place is busted right
like it makes more sense that i was
supposed to go in that room
there's nothing like there's gates here
i can't leave
if you guys have any suggestions send
them my way at this stage i feel like
i'm a little
i'm not sure what to do
oh i don't want to start over can i kill
myself
i don't even know how i would do that
because there's really no way to die in
here
i've done it
congratulations everyone
oh damn it i have to do this part over
again that's okay
um
all right where am i
let's collect our bearing shall we
i remember being dropped here and being
freaked out
and seeing there we go
there are those
so dark in here
where the [__] am i supposed to go
i just did this part right
did it send me somewhere new
well i have to find the place to jump
over if i'm going to jump over the
railing
like i jumped over the railing onto a
floor i didn't just jump over it to kill
myself unless you want me to kill myself
again
to kill myself again
well the devs told me kill myself here
we go
okay
sounds like the developer's in the chat
if anyone has any questions they could
probably ask the developer directly
because
i'm not
completely sure what i'm supposed to do
i could try killing myself again
we
oh my god
like any particular type of tilde
just as it is
holding it down
hmm
um okay so i'm supposed to follow the
path to be able to get back to where i
was
so this path i assume
is that what we're talking about
okay okay
okay cool i found a hidey hole
i believe this is gonna get me back
where i was cool okay i think we're back
on track
um this is the part where i jumped
these guys aren't here anymore
i
go this way
you can so easily get
turned around in this place
that's where i came from okay so i'm
taking a left
there we go okay
[__]
where am i going
sit things are moving i can hear gears
i've changed the world
okay
this where the stairs were
right
am i nutso
all right i need
a little bit more light
in this room
you guys can probably see it better than
me for the record i have a big light on
my freaking face and in dark areas i
can't see
no that's a ceiling
did i ruin it should i kill myself again
there's no way to fix it
i have to start over
damn it
i really don't want to start all the way
all right
that sucks i really wanted to see the
end
because i think the demo
tay come in here
if
do you guys have a lot of [__] to do
cause i'll start it over and beat it
if you guys don't mind we'll just walk
away
all right this sucks sorry guys sounds
like i broke the game
which happens it's demo like
no this isn't the final product this is
something that people are working on
and
i can get that um
i mean overall it's still like a
gorgeous game and
seems like they're just
still i'm i'm kind of like
helping solve some of these issues i
probably found something weird going on
um
but i'm learning each time and because i
remember the first time i had to restart
i was able to finish i was able to get
back where i was in like five minutes
so i feel like if i do this again
ideally i should be able to
get back where i was in like 10 15
minutes so if you guys want to bear with
me
um i'd love to try to finish this
i was told that the dev believes in me
thank you
i'm definitely interested
sorry for the issues you guys but i i do
want to finish this and at least i
assume i'm pretty far along it felt like
it can't be that much
and even if it is like i don't care
i don't care
bring it on
i know i'm in a cage
i'm going to sit in this chair
and i'm learning things each time like i
learned not to go through windows and
this last time i learned that if there's
a room
get your butt in that room before
pushing the button
it's just very likely
bubbles
glitch the game out
so hopefully that's the last
of that issue and i'll just kind of try
to speed through it okay so
first things first i need
let's push this button
then
again maybe i can speed run this um
okay wait what am i doing all right i
went
in here
i think
i don't even remember
i'm
i'm going too fast you guys
all right so there's a key in the toilet
here
okay
that key unlocks
something
oh no
don't you dare
i'm finishing this
again
i wonder if that was happening with the
window if i would have just freaked out
a little bit more i would have been fine
you know like
that's such a thing you know like
i do i need to oh do i need to read the
paper can i like just not read it i'm
just going to read it
the developer will yell at me if i
required to read paper um i came here to
play
not read
all right here we go
where am i going this is right right am
i nutso
then i follow the tracks right
oh my god i can't even remember it's how
to do this i think i followed the tracks
pretty sure
nice try window
i've been tricked by windows before
okay
okay here we go all right so
oh look i'm in that room
do i not even need to do that
you guys messing with me
oh i do need to do it because there's
the
thing
i'm confusing myself now
i really am
so if i push that
oh my god
what did i do did i just kill myself
that's weird i think i did it a
completely different way that time
i don't think that was how it was
intended to be played
but i also
don't care
i was
that was not
what i was supposed to do
okay
whatever
don't care
it's funny that you can do things
different ways i like i like that i
assume it's intended that i can actually
go
different roundabout ways to get to the
final
to product it's just interesting to kind
of solve it in a different way this time
it gives me more perspective on the
puzzle i don't know if that's like
technically a puzzle
all right
so
already much further
along hope you guys are still with me
this is still fun
creepy dude
there should be a key
i'll peep this guy out
peep peep all right
all right so push
uh the buttons
let's see i can't remember
the problem with this layout
um
is that it's
really easy to get
turned around
and
um
sure
no bad touching
no throwing garbage into the dark no
off-kilter talk
say
your pleas and thank yous resonate with
joy respect your elders accept your
punishment
what does no bad touching mean does that
mean good touching is allowed
and if so that's inappropriate
okay
so
this is where i'm supposed to go in the
end
where are those buttons
oh i know there's one down here i
remember
oh
boop
okay
this was the
chambery thing
door
okay
i think i need to do a little bit oh
there we go
two and then there's one in the bathroom
do you guys remember where the bathroom
is i gotta go to the bathroom oh god
so embarrassing this is where i came
from
where's the bathroom
i know
it's so funny i just freaking did this
but it's honestly a little bit of a
labyrinth in there and
to a degree i'm sure they knew that when
they made this and they wanted me to be
super confused that's fine
that's fine you know like whatever
but
i get the higher
i get really frustrated
oh god i gotta get out of here i
remember
they squished that part
i bet you people died there other
testers
other
all right okay
make them prog
make progress here we go oh yeah
electricity
button
we can do this
there's not a key over here right
like i don't even technically need any
of this stuff i think i can just keep
going
i'll just push it again
pretty sure
uh what was up here i think it's just
another freaking note i'll just check
real fast
just in case because if it's a key i'll
be really bummed
all right whatever
there's no time to read
i was told i can't keep the stream going
forever so i'm going to try to beat it
as soon as possible alright so this is
when i meet the creepy dudes
let me get my shift key ready
see you [__]
okay this is when they get mad at me
oh i guess i did kill them right because
this isn't them oh [__] i died
i was too excited
that's right because
captured by the albinos
i guess that's what it looks like when
you die
don't stand too close to them for too
long
i don't like that it says that to me all
right let's try it again
um
yeah i guess like
when they were all dead next to me i was
like that's not my fault but i guess it
is because when i
made all these things move they all
shook around
and i i killed them
when i did that
um so i guess it's reasonable that
they're a little angry with me
although i'm pretty sure that they've
done really messed up stuff
to other people so there's a little bit
of a discrepancy with who's to blame
here
alright
so
fix
all right
so these guys die and i gotta find the
exit right there's an exit
open
go upstairs
this
button
then i think i push it again
until a piece of the floor opens up
i'll just do it again
is it done okay
so that's why like sometimes i feel like
i'm not sure if i i glitched the game or
if it's meant to be because there are
times in the game where you're supposed
to push a button multiple times and then
there's other times
where it's actually super rude and
you're breaking [__] and it's
i want an impacty noise when i fall
you know
oh okay all right
i'm back
where i was
the game
is lit so i'm pretty sure oh okay yeah
this is where i realized all right we're
good we're doing good
creepy guy
this guy runs away from me
what is that
it reminds me of slimer
oh okay all right
this is the part where it's like
oh there we go
i don't know where i am
okay here we
go
okay
you know it's it's interesting like i
don't know how long that was i don't
know if someone can tell me but uh i
just got back to exactly where i was
pretty quickly so it seems like this
game is really more about like
exploration
and like slowly figuring stuff out than
it is
you know like puzzle-based games are
always like that you play them again and
you beat them in like two minutes
my co-workers are trying to scare me
again they're doing a [__] job
all right i am back where i was
so i don't want to freak anyone
out by making any mistakes
i'm going to take my time and let him
finish his statement about being angry
with me
it's not my fault i mean it's my fault
it's also yours
let's agree to disagree
i mean i gotta say like i do love
all right
the look of this game like what's that
button for
i'm just getting angry
what is that button for
you told me from the very beginning to
not push a button and it ended up being
the right thing to do
so it only seems to be reasonable that i
would push a button
okay
all right i'm in a new spot
hooray
remember to prevent walk walking
escape i wonder if that's me
because i'm the only one who can walk
the lamp must be lit using the horrible
blue matches before the gate can be
opened so
it sounds
to me like somebody doesn't like the
blue lights
which means
i'm totally gonna make everything blue
because then
you'll have to f off
i bet you because you know now i think
about it a lot of
the level is like kind of
pinky orangey
and i'm making it blue
oh it's all that [__]
chains okay
oh no
so hard to tell if i'm doing this right
those stairs
i know what stairs look like
i've seen stairs before
i've seen many a stare in my day
oh
i thought that was the thing
that's
yeah it's funny it's like
i played this before
you know so when i was playing through
all the things i played through before i
wasn't i wasn't scared because i'd been
through it but you know i'm here in a
new spot and i'm scared all over again
because
what makes it scary
has always been the anticipation
you know
and
this game is freaking scary
[__]
what
what's that
it's a piece of paper
on what
can i light you on fire
i was as is you not yet one of them was
in cell just next door managed escape
but here i decay baking and cell caught
eyes gone legs almost gone
will gone
the grandmother will she ever die
hideous abomination found this key go up
the grand staircase okay i remember that
place
unlock the metal door find the thing
they call bucks clicker
the key to our freedom return here use
bucks clicker to free me and in return
i show you the way out love
piotr p
piatrer please don't
please not my phone
i did before i read that but that's not
fair because i
i hadn't read the rule
when you told me oh
peter
look the shadows kind of look like i'm
flicking you off
oh his little eye holes he's got no
poor peter
all right
where am i going
am i going this way
i'm going this way
i'm going to the light
nope that's a closed area
i hope
i'm second guessing myself the loading
screen like ensures that i'm
going the right way i believe
where am i supposed to be going
i want to go towards this light but i
don't
this is where it came from right
god i hope i don't glitch the game
i was so close they'll say
oh oh
is that the moon
oh it's just a light
in my defense
that seems reasonable
okay
sorry i'm having trouble seeing i'm kind
of like
making my best guess i actually thought
i was going to like get ground up in
those gears
but it seems like this is the right
oh god please no
boop
oh
it's a grinder
and a chair
who will win
currently chair is doing really good
but the grinder
is not giving up
it's anyone's game
go chair
i've always been an underdog rooter
well it looks like it's a draw
okay
should i go in there should i
investigate i can't really see
i think i can hear them
okay so i can't go that way
i'd really like to turn it up i can't
really hear what they're saying
thank you
does he see me
okay
well fine
oh god he found me
he did kill me
okay
i must be sneakier
sneaky
is my middle name
it's not it's elizabeth
well
they started me here
where am i
whoa whoa whoa how far back did i go
did i go back really far is that what
just happened
am i redoing what i just did
because i've already done this
damn
i'm gonna try to finish it if you guys
got stuff to do though i'll quit
oh crap
i think
that's weird the floor didn't turn that
time
i'll probably
oh wait i might have actually glitched
it i think i glitched it again
i think i might have glitched the game
again if i did i'm probably not going to
start from the beginning again although
i really would like to finish it but i'm
kind of hoping they'll put me
somewhere new
damn
sucks like i know i was here before so
it looks like what it did was it
yeah it's doing it again where the floor
is
the same like the floor isn't moving
into the correct spot
it looks like because i'm in the same
spot that i was prior it considered this
an old save spot even though i was in a
new
section of gameplay
again like totally something that
happens when a game is like in
development
and it's still like
scary and
ah
sounds like they're gonna send us
another build
that might be that might uh fix some of
these issues
yeah it's still busted
damn
all right well it seems like
i'm gonna have to quit again
that really sucks i'm not gonna give you
guys the satisfaction of killing me i'm
gonna quit
i'll just go suck it
well that was a albino lullaby um i mean
it's it's still like a gorgeous game
it's definitely creepy and i'm
interested to like see more i would have
loved to finish it um i'm definitely
gonna try
um on i'll just kind of keep going
probably and maybe record it so we can
see what the ending is it looks like a
sweet game and i'll definitely like to
see more of it so i hope you guys liked
it
it's definitely different than the
normal kinds of creepy games i've been
playing it's not so much like a jump
scare thing it's more of like a just a
creepy environment i bet you it does get
more creepy it sounds like it was about
to get
to the type of thing where i'd have to
like creep around and you know like
avoid being seen and stuff like that so
uh probably a lot more to see with this
game um
let's see ape law is who made it that's
the indie game studios you probably uh
look up 8th law to find out more about
albino lullaby and i do believe they
have a kickstarter on right now so
that's it for this now playing thanks
for joining me and i'll talk to you guys
later bye